ya es de noche cuando la policía lanza
un asalto en esta parcela de un barrio
popular deprisa
objetivo del operativo desmantelar una
invasión de consumidores de bomba una
droga artesanal a buen precio muy tóxica
y adictiva fabricada a base de
medicamentos tales como el opio y de
tramadol y residuos filtrados por los
exhaustos sumerge a los drogadictos en
un estado de 2ª lencia
aquí están parecen cadáveres están
drogados a muerte estas son las drogas
mezcla de productos farmacéuticos drogas
entre otros si lo usas ya no hay nada
que hacer razón por la cual estamos
determinados a ponerle fin a esta
práctica en conchas llévense los
uno a uno son desalojados a punta de
teis er y bolillo
el método es brutal y puede parecer
excesivo bajo el efecto de la droga a
los detenidos apenas se debaten pero los
policías hacen su trabajo con orgullo
frente a nuestras cámaras
afuera a los consumidores son amarrados
y apilados en el suelo alertados por el
ruido decenas de vecinos asisten a la
escena algunos relatan que el barrio se
había vuelto invisible por el tráfico y
los invaden si usted deja una camisa una
silla unos cuantos minutos después de la
llevan
esto no es colombia que no nos invadan
de droga en todas partes
desde finales de agosto la policía de
kinshasa ha multiplicado las
intervenciones antidrogas consumidores
traficantes y fabricantes son detenidos
sistemáticamente esta droga bomba es
prácticamente un arma de destrucción
masiva
atacaremos sin cesar a los vendedores y
a los jóvenes que consumen para salvar a
nuestra población el operativo termina
en menos de una hora los vehículos de
policías se van aplaudidos por los
habitantes
gente que duerme de pie y deambula en
las calles tambaleándose las imágenes
dieron la vuelta en las redes sociales
en el congo kinshasa la progresión de la
bomba no sólo preocupa a las autoridades
no estamos de acuerdo con el uso de la
bomba es un elemento que está
destruyendo nuestras costumbres en este
último tiempo han detenido a mucha gente
en el barrio eso está bien y deben
continuar cuando los encierran dan una
lección a quienes quedan en libertad y
esto puede conducirlos a parar no todo
el mundo comparte esa opinión hay
asociaciones que tratan de ayudar a
dichos jóvenes
vengan vamos a comer primero así
recuperarán fuerza
como cada día a día ni su equipo
distribuyen gratuitamente alimentos a
los drogadictos del barrio para ella la
represión policial no es una solución
siempre ha habido detenciones de
drogadictos pero ello no ha impedido que
la gente consuma droga aquí en el
terreno usted puede ver que en la
mayoría de los drogadictos están
enfermos necesitan ayuda médica deben
ser sanadas una observación compartida
por los consumidores porque más allá de
la dependencia y ser presionados por los
traficantes que inundan el mercado si
quieres parar solo la bomba no lo
lograrás te dan crisis terminarás
muriendo por nada
cada mañana debes tomar tu dosis para
sentirte bien durante el día
además es muy fácil encontrarla los
vendedores no se esconden están por
todas partes puedes comprar bombé por
mil francos o dos mil francos a unas
cuantas calles de aquí la ong tos son
ghana plus instaló sus oficinas en una
pequeña clínica debido a la droga
numerosos consumidores sufren
infecciones respiratorias y trastornos
neurológicos pero a pocos los atienden
por falta de recursos
la voluntad de estar
contamos con los expertos que pueden
ayudar a estas personas
pero los medicamentos cuestan
según algunos expertos los cuidados
duran mínimo 6 meses
en la alcaldía el gobernador dice asumir
su elección de una política de represión
tras su detención cientos consumidores
son enviados con otros delincuentes a la
provincia de katanga al sur del país
para trabajar en los campos
cuando enviamos a la gente acá en llamas
ese no solo es para los campos allá hay
una especie de reinserción hay escuelas
de oficios muchos aprenden carpintería
plomería todos esos oficios
la reinserción que sigue siendo marginal
según una encuesta de la onu cerca del
80% de los jóvenes congoleses están
desempleados